este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
bling ist haber una pregunta se sincero
se te acumulan las lecturas pendientes
no consigues leer todo lo que te
propones procrastinar reconócelo nos
pasa a todos pues atentos porque bling
bling ist es para ti en bling is podrás
encontrar miles de libros de no ficción
en inglés resumidos en 15 minutos y ojo
porque aparte de leerlos también puedes
escuchar los que oye por un lado puedes
ir aprovechando tiempo mientras vas en
el metro o limpias tu casa y por otro
por otro podrás hacer oído con el inglés
muchas veces nos pedís que os
recomendamos libros pues mirad
precisamente en blink éste encontrareis
muchos de los que siempre os
recomendamos apuestas seguras como por
ejemplo facts funes freakonomics o
porque fracasan los países también
tienes títulos recién estrenados como
una tierra prometida la primera parte de
las memorias presidenciales de barack
obama pero aquí viene lo mejor los
primeros 100 de vosotros que vayáis a
bling east puntocom
vp tendréis acceso ilimitado por una
semana para probar bling is total
gratis si no os convence podéis
cancelarlo sin problema durante esos
siete días y en caso de que os guste ya
veréis cómo es que si disfrutaréis
también además de un 25% de descuento
para un full membership y sin más sin
más arranquemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el pasado noviembre del 2020 se
celebraron las elecciones más polémicas
de la historia de los eeuu seguro que
todos recordáis perfectamente el lo que
pasó el incremento de la participación
el voto por correo el vuelco a favor de
los demócratas y las acusaciones de todo
tipo sin ningún fundamento que
terminaron con el asalto al mismísimo
capitolio sin embargo amigos amigas de
visual político esa experiencia sirvió
para que de repente surgieran muchas
preguntas sobre cómo funciona
exactamente la democracia norteamericana
y especialmente sobre los instrumentos
que hacen que los resultados electorales
no siempre se correspondan con lo que
vota la mayoría de la gente y no no
estoy hablando de las denuncias vertidas
por trump o el tío de los cuernos del
capitolio sino más bien de cosas como el
jerry mandarín
[Música]
un instrumento político bastante
desconocido fuera de eeuu pero que es
toda una máquina para distorsionar los
resultados electorales y ojo porque todo
esto no lo invento ni vaivén ni clinton
ni obama ni ningún supervillano hablamos
de una práctica con más de dos siglos de
antigüedad a la que recurren por igual
los representantes del partido demócrata
y del partido republicano así que la
pregunta es qué es el jerry mandarín
porque no es ilegal y lo que es más
importante que puede suponer el jerry
mandarín en los próximos años hoy en
visual político vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas pero antes antes
vamos a ver un poquito de historia
[Música]
la salamandra de jerry
el sistema electoral de eeuu es complejo
y mucho menos se resume en ver quién
obtiene más votos recuerda por ejemplo
lo que ocurrió en 2016 cuando trump ganó
las elecciones a pesar de tener 3
millones de votos menos que hillary
clinton algo que por cierto ha ocurrido
ya en cinco ocasiones siempre ha
beneficiado al partido republicano son
cosas del colegio electoral aún así esto
no tiene nada que ver con la
manipulación del jerry mandarín
eeuu es una federación de 50 estados que
se han ido incorporando con cuentagotas
desde 1787 hoy en día su forma federal
está absolutamente consolidada pero las
diferencias entre los diversos estados
han sido patentes a lo largo de los años
llegando incluso a las manos con la
guerra civil de mediados del siglo 19
por eso desde el principio se puso en
marcha un sistema electoral ideado para
cumplir una misión evitar la victoria de
un candidato apoyado solo por una región
del país aunque ese apoyo fuera muy muy
fuerte por eso en eeuu no votan
directamente al presidente sino al
colegio electoral y el que saca más
votos en un estado se lleva todos los
votos de ese estado en el colegio
electoral da igual cuánto de fuerte sea
el margen de victoria ya llega en el
estado por un punto por 25 los delegados
que se obtienen son los mismos
[Música]
esto es lo que explica que no haya
correspondencia entre el voto popular y
el resultado de la elección presidencial
pero que no haya proporcionalidad en las
presidenciales significa ni mucho menos
que haya manipulación aquí no actúa el
jerry mander in el jerry mander bien se
utiliza en las elecciones legislativas
tanto para las del parlamento de cada
estado como para la cámara de
representantes a nivel federal porque
pues porque las presidenciales cada
estado forma una circunscripción única
sin embargo en las elecciones
legislativas el territorio de cada
estado se divide para asignar un escaño
a cada distrito y como los encargados de
dividir el territorio son los propios
políticos al final
jerry mander bien produce efectos tan
escandalosos como este los republicanos
obtuvieron el 50,3 por ciento de los
votos de carolina del norte para el
congreso se hicieron con 10 de los 13
escaños 10 de 13 supone un 77% de los
parlamentarios que carolina del norte
tiene en la cámara de representantes de
esta forma los demócratas con el 40
por ciento de los votos solo recibieron
un 23 por ciento de los escaños y aquí
justo aquí es donde actúa el jerry
mander in porque los distritos no son
como los estados que están definidos
geográficamente los distritos van
cambiando periódicamente tanto para la
legislatura estatal como para la cámara
de representantes- cada diez años se
divide el territorio en tantos distritos
como escaños se pongan en juego el único
requisito es que todos los distritos
tengan más o menos la misma cantidad de
personas y luego el candidato más votado
se lleva el escaño de cada distrito
por eso el cómo se trazan exactamente
los mapas de los distritos tiene una
importancia brutal porque hay dos formas
de trazar los puede hacerse como se hace
en el estado de iowa donde para dibujar
los distritos se utiliza un software
informático diseñado para evitar la
división de los condados y que no tiene
en cuenta los intereses políticos claro
hecho así los distritos son casi
modélicos pero hay amigos en la mayor
parte de los estados ha sido
tradicionalmente el partido político que
domina la asamblea legislativa estatal
quien traza los distritos electorales y
cuando recurren al jerry mander in los
mapas de distritos empiezan a tener
formas muy extrañas como de extrañas
pues tan extrañas como esta del cuarto
distrito congresional de illinois
[Aplausos]
pero a estas alturas puede que muchos os
estáis preguntando gerrymandering pero
por qué demonios se llama así no pueden
decir algo más simple como que manipulan
apañan o retuercen los mapas para
salirse con la suya en las elecciones
pues amigos amigas para explicar por qué
se llama gerrymandering tenemos que
remontarnos a 1812
por aquel entonces el gobernador de
massachusetts el brie thierry frémaux
alguna medida que modificaba los
distritos para darle una ventaja
electoral a su partido el partido
demócrata republicano fundado por thomas
jefferson el nuevo distrito tenía una
forma extraña y un periódico el botón
gasset publicó esta caricatura el nuevo
distrito adoptaba la forma de una
salamandra y así nació el término del
jerry mander de la combinación del
apellido del gobernador jerry con la
palabra salamandra en inglés salamander
curioso no os parece el caso es que el
objetivo del diario mandarín es muy
simple trazar los distritos legislativos
maximizando tus posibilidades mientras
minimiza las opciones del rival y muchos
diréis pero bueno esto no parece
exactamente lo que podríamos calificar
como fair play es que acaso nadie lo
intenta impedir pues la respuesta es que
si uno es william whitford un profesor
de derecho en la universidad de
wisconsin que denuncia el jerry mander y
que han practicado los republicanos en
este estado
[Música]
ya sabéis una idea en las últimas
elecciones los candidatos del partido
demócrata se hicieron con el 53 por
ciento de los votos pero apenas se
quedaron con el 38 por ciento de los
parlamentarios ojo los demócratas
también lo utilizan cuando pueden en
maryland por ejemplo si señalan los
mapas para hacerse con siete de los ocho
distritos que se ponen en juego de cara
a la cámara de representantes el caso es
que el bueno de whitford tiene muy claro
que es exactamente el jerry mander y no
en una democracia se supone que los
ciudadanos eligen a sus legisladores en
wisconsin los legisladores han elegido a
sus votantes mediante la redistribución
de distritos que hace prácticamente
imposible que los demócratas obtengan
una mayoría en la asamblea estatal sin
importar cuántos votos obtengan en todo
el estado para los candidatos demócratas
william whitford profesor emérito de
derecho en la universidad de wisconsin
el profesor whitford llegó hasta el
tribunal supremo sin mucho éxito que
digamos pero queréis saber cómo se han
pronunciado en los tribunales al
respecto pues atentos
por cierto stop os acordáis de las
camisetas que antes os he enseñado de
esta camiseta os gusta pues forma parte
de una serie de productos exclusivos que
hemos separado para todos los patrón de
nivel 3 o superior así que si quieres
apoyar a visual político conseguir
además productos exclusivos como este no
te olvides de echar un vistazo a nuestro
patrón patrón puntocom barra visual
política y ahora si continuemos
[Música]
gerrymandering caso cerrado
el jerry mander inga ha sido abordado
por el tribunal supremo de eeuu en
numerosas ocasiones y la respuesta dada
por el máximo tribunal federal siempre
ha sido la misma no es muy elegante pero
no es un asunto que el poder judicial
pueda controlar aunque en el 2004 estuvo
a punto de ser diferente cuando los
nueve jueces que integran el tribunal
supremo se dividieron ante la
posibilidad de poner límites a german
behring pero al final todo siguió igual
el juez decisivo para decantar la
balanza argumentó que el problema era
que aún no se había encontrado la
fórmula para imponer restricciones a
jerry mander in que no supusiera una
intromisión sustancial en la vida
política de la nación 14 años después en
2018 el jerry mander in volvió a ser
protagonista en el tribunal supremo y
volvió a salir airoso el tribunal
supremo- se niega a establecer límites
al jerry mentir y político a grandes
rasgos lo que ha venido a decir el
tribunal supremo sobre el diario
mandarín es que es mucho mejor no
meterse en política que eso es cosa de
las cámaras estatales siempre y cuando
eso sí no se utilice para perjudicar a
una minoría a la que se pretende
discriminar
por motivos raciales
en definitiva el tribunal supremo de
eeuu ha dado luz verde a jerry mander in
con intereses partidistas superado el
escollo judicial la única barrera para
el jerry mander in viene de iniciativas
como la de wauters not politicians
hablamos de unos activistas de michigan
que consiguieron el apoyo necesario para
que los ciudadanos de este estado puedan
votar en un referéndum si querían o no
acabar de una vez por todas con esta
práctica
wouters not politicians logró su
objetivo y el diseño de los distritos
electorales en michigan ha recaído en
manos de una comisión integrada a partes
iguales por representantes de los dos
principales partidos y ciudadanos
elegidos por sorteo comisiones similares
funcionan en arizona y california desde
hace décadas e iniciativas como la de
wauters not politicians han sido
replicadas en otros estados como
colorado yuta y misurí esto está muy
bien pero hay dos problemas primero que
esta vía de la iniciativa no vale para
todos porque apenas está contemplada en
otra decena de estados y el segundo es
que el ser humano muchas veces es
bastante contradictorios y amigos en
misurí lo es aún más
los votantes derogan el plan de
redistribución de distritos de klee
missouri que promulgaron en 2018 pero
como os quedáis si os digo que todo esto
del jordi mandarín amenaza a la mayoría
del partido demócrata en las próximas
elecciones atentos
el censo
cada 10 años se repite la misma película
en los eeuu todos los años que terminan
en 0 como el pasado 2020 son años
descenso y el censo desencadena a nivel
político un proceso la redistribución de
distritos los 435 miembros de la cámara
de representantes se redistribuyen cada
10 años para dar más representación a
los estados que han ganado más población
frente a aquellos que han perdido
población o han crecido en menor medida
para luego censo ha sido muy importante
el cambio en la casa blanca es que
veréis una de las últimas medidas de
trump fue excluir a los inmigrantes
ilegales de los recuentos oficiales del
censo algo que bailén anuló al día
siguiente de su toma de posesión y que
curiosamente puede tener malas
consecuencias para su partido el partido
demócrata al derogar la orden del censo
de trans sobre inmigrantes ilegales va a
ir en simplemente le dio al partido
republicano de texas 12 escaños está la
cámara efectivamente se espera que
dejase al estado más beneficiado con la
nueva redistribución con lo dispuesto
por trump y va a ganar sólo un
representante pero al contar también a
los inmigrantes
se espera que la teja se lleve hasta
tres nuevos escaños y florida
otros dos hablamos de dos feudos
republicanos desde hace más de veinte
años por el contrario bastiones del
partido demócrata como illinois nueva
york y california perderán escaños y ojo
porque en las últimas elecciones en la
cámara de representantes los demócratas
apenas tuvieron una ventaja de nueve
representantes
así que todo indica que los republicanos
podrían hacerse con la mayoría de la
cámara en las elecciones de mitad de
mandato de 2022 simplemente gracias a la
nueva redistribución sin necesidad de
ganar más apoyo
y aquí es muy pero que muy importante
subrayar la importancia del jerry mander
porque pues porque este incremento de
población de texas y florida proviene en
su mayor parte del crecimiento de la
periferia de las grandes ciudades y lo
cierto es que el votante urbano tiende a
votar a los demócratas de hecho los
alcaldes de las 10 ciudades más grandes
de eeuu son del partido demócrata por
eso el jerry mander in jugará un papel
decisivo al elaborar los distritos de
esta forma el partido republicano
combinará áreas rurales con zonas
próximas a las ciudades para que sus
candidatos tienen las de ganar de hecho
ya se habla de que están trabajando
sobre los mapas de lugares como houston
atlanta y ohio para hacerse con nuevos
distritos pero ojo que esto no es algo
exclusivo de los republicanos el partido
demócrata se está preparando para hacer
lo mismo con los territorios que
controlan fijos por ejemplo en el caso
de nueva york- los legisladores
estatales demócratas se preparan para
rediseñar sus propias líneas de distrito
para asegurarse su mayoría durante los
próximos años recientemente el partido
demócrata aprobó en la cámara de
representantes- la llamada ley para el
pueblo un proyecto
muy amplio que acaba de una vez por
todas con el jerry mander y claro que al
final no pasará nada porque la ley
necesita una mayoría reforzada de 60
votos en el senado y el texto el texto
contempla demasiadas cuestiones como
para convencer a los senadores
republicanos que harían falta y ojo
porque otra consecuencia directa de toda
esta práctica es que resulte auténtica
gasolina para polarizar el debate y la
acción política fijaos
prácticamente garantiza que un partido
arrasa en un distrito así que la
verdadera batalla para los candidatos
está en ganar las primarias y en
conseguir la nominación de su partido
para ese distrito las elecciones
primarias de los partidos suelen
favorecer que los candidatos más
radicales traten de hacerse con el apoyo
de los suyos con su éxito se desprecian
otras posiciones más moderadas
en fin amigos así están las cosas pero
llegas a este punto turno para ti
consideráis que debe respetarse el jerry
mandarín porque así son las reglas del
juego y lo practican ambos partidos por
igual o creéis que será mejor que se
limitarán de una vez por todas podéis
dejarnos vuestra respuesta aquí abajo en
los comentarios si este vídeo que ha
resultado interesante darle al botón de
like y no olvides suscribirte abisal
político si aún no lo has hecho un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]